[Music]
and thirty three lines
17:33 pressure building is lines for
protocol accepted
daddy's listening can you say hi and how
big are you I mean can you tell that how
big you are are you so big your brain
and can you sing but singing how about I
miss you and I love you I love you daddy
allow me daddy and I can't wait to see
who can you see see you
[Music]
detected this is UNSC Pelican echo 216
can you hear me
this is us
[Music]
[Music]
looks like the main power cells are
fried auto shutdown triggering survival
mode I'm going to try to overwrite
okay
you can hear me in there
I hope you're ready please don't die
Oh welcome back chief I rerouted what
needle power ahead into your suit hmm
looks like there's a problem with the
servos in your hands stay calm
you've been out there a while I know I
saw something in here to check your
armors Diagnostics
oh you see their big I know not status
report status report
what there's something you need to see
chief
we lost
lost everything there's nothing left for
us
13:48
[Music]
not this not again we need to run
no we need to fight
get ready
[Music]
I chose you because you were special
[Music]
I knew it would be perfect together
and I was right
[Music]